[Music]
hey folks here we are we might be drunk
we got a full house today huh oh my God
Sally baby we got Jamie
jamo good to have you back it's been
about a year
yeah all right well you didn't do a
great job so we wanted you to build your
what do we have today what are we
drinking well you need to take a break
so oh you have some healthy juices here
to help you guys detox from whatever
happened to you over the weekend it's
been rough yeah people assume we just
drink on this podcast
[Laughter]
well soon it's we had a rough weekend oh
what's it would we know what's in these
yes talk to us judging by the colors I'd
say there's carrot in there some kind of
green veggies and a little bit
everything from the earth just to help
you out all right well Chase it with a
little Pedialyte yeah how you doing you
straw oh the paper I really don't like
the paper straw
I hate it I don't like it
they get mushy
the turtle thing's a myth they made that
all up oh this tastes pretty good I
taste a little ginger in here
Ginger I'm being healthy this week
that's the Irish people
I closed a Barb on Saturday night and
it's like
there's no worse feeling when you're in
a bar and someone flips the lights on ah
the worst it's so aggressive yeah you
see the the Cockroaches you see the dirt
on the ground is it passed out dude and
you see how ugly everyone really is you
know because with the booze and the
lights off people looking pretty good
yeah
the Cockroaches and the one old guy at
the end of the bar the two survivors
yeah exactly nuclear Holocaust wouldn't
get rid of them so I got I saw something
on the street of my way here and I had
to grab it for the studio this is a real
Salamanca move but I pulled it this week
saw a guy selling records oh
yeah hey all right I just thought it was
a cool look this prior one check this
[ __ ] out I think I've ever seen that
yeah I don't know this special actually
uh but look
I thought this just looked cool as hell
that's gorgeous doesn't look good yeah I
love it what year do you think that is
it's got to be 79 yeah 80. what year was
Sunset Strip I've got the computer here
what am I doing there you go Google
[ __ ] this is 78. oh got it
all right that's exciting finally we
have a black on the wall it was getting
a little weird we got Pryor up there
already oh we do okay we need we need
the ones we need are Patrice Carlin and
he said the guy in the shoes I was like
who else you got to do I'm due for Joan
Rivers I was like we should have Joan on
that one Joan for sure let's get a lady
up there she met Joan did you before she
says how was that I met her twice in the
same day at two different situations so
my mom got to meet her the first time
which was awesome and then I got to her
book signing so I had she wrote me like
a nice message wow in her last book that
she came out with so wow that forever
that's amazing I saw Patton Oswalt made
a great point about how like you know
everybody gets mad about jokes and
offended or whatever and he's like she
was a woman doing it and opened the door
so like imagine Foster a lot though it
cost her a lot but imagine if she didn't
sacrifice we might not have any uh funny
ladies
yeah that was his point and also in that
documentary of her you see like there's
that guy with the guys like offended and
she's like [ __ ] you like I was like [ __ ]
you she's like cool when an older lady
says that yeah shut the [ __ ] up I mean
you watch her I used to watch the
fashion show because I thought she was
funny and she would just be like what
are you wearing you [ __ ] look like
hell and you're like what the hell but
she was so ghoulish and old that you let
it slide well she was a cartoon
character the way Rodney was yes where
she was like ow ow like that voice
that's cartoony you get away with being
meaner same with Rickles he's [ __ ] Mr
Potato Head in Toy Story when you're a
cartoon looking dude you can get away
with saying some [ __ ] when you look like
that you can [ __ ] on Sinatra and they're
like ah he's lovable yeah he would trash
Sinatra and they would all Just Go With
It yeah and Sinatra like you when you're
that arrogant and you're that much of a
complete lunatic you have like one
friend that's allowed to [ __ ] on you but
you know anyone else that [ __ ] on
Sinatra he was probably like he's out
that's true what is it about Joan Rivers
is from Brooklyn Rickles is from Queens
Dangerfield is from Queens insane that
just that tri-state area has bred so
much Larry David Brooklyn Seinfeld
Brooklyn Chris uh Chris rocks Brooklyn
but then the last generation Woody Allen
he was like very Boston if you think of
all that that's true it's like Louie
Burr you know uh David Cross like all
these great comedians
Patrice Patrice
the funnier you get
yeah yeah I mean Albert Brooks he had a
regular life he's L.A he's very funny
yeah I think you could I think it's
funny I think it's there's a good
combination with Boston and New York
with blue collar meets
Scholastic
you got you got Colombia here you got
NYU here you got the other one and then
you got uh Boston's MIT Harvard and uh
but yet they're all working in a mill
they're all [ __ ] Irish and angry and
they [ __ ] with each other it's a good
mix New York we're all in everything
together like Bloomberg took the subway
yeah I mean like I know it's a publicity
thing but like it is actually the best
way to get around so you think about
that like Bloomberg and a guy sucking on
his foot in the same subway car right
there's something beautiful about that
yes you know that's true there's a guy
jerking it and uh Koch Koch took this up
guy jerking is Jeffrey tuben on the same
subway car just jerking his dick there
you go
yeah Seinfeld always said that like New
York keeps you funny because you can't
you can't like relax well there's so
much stimulus like you go to go to
Westchester and you're like what am I
doing there's nothing to do exactly
nothing shuts the brain off like just
boredom like you can take a million
different reps home in New York just
walking like I'm gonna go this this is
the direction I'm gonna go and you'll
see a different thing there's a dead guy
this way is a hobo that way there's a
Girl Scout it's everything yeah and
they say comedy goes up during you know
[ __ ] times
you know because you need it so it's
like you said huh when are good times
though everything every time is kind of
[ __ ] right well it's always [ __ ] to
somebody like people say hey the 50s it
was magical it was uh you know unlock
your door and families and suburbs and
all that but then black people were
getting [ __ ] over and women and women
and black women yeah maybe some Jews
yeah oh yeah commies Kami the Red Scare
yeah that's true everything was people
were like you know these are tough times
really and what were the Crusades easy
it's never good there's always something
the 90s weren't bad
I like the 90s Meredith Brooks I'm a
[ __ ] those are simpler times Well
Rodney King had a rough go
OJ got off
his wife didn't but yeah what does that
mean call it even
yeah all right
I haven't happened at the end of the 90s
and 2000s and it was all downhill yeah I
mean flying before 9 11. oh holy [ __ ]
great Daniel Tosh joke uh 911 sucks is
or I like it because I used to have to
walk with my girlfriend to the gate
I love that joke
that's good I remember going with
girlfriends like to the airport you just
have to wait there yeah so the flight
took off
what about uh how is Houston over the
weekend ah Houston Houston
is better than Austin I'm saying it
right now Austin's all hip and cool keep
it weird everybody's moving there
Houston's a better city is Houston here
number one in Texas
probably yeah it's very diverse it
doesn't get as due for diversity it's
every group every race Vietnamese pop
huge Vietnamese Indian uh they're all
overweight so that brings them together
but because it's the foodie City it's
huge food and it's got a little
everything and it's got different
neighborhoods that are very interesting
and uh I love Houston great crowds great
Club Great crowds how'd you like it you
were just there I had a great time I was
worried that your tickets would hurt
mine
uh yeah I worry about that too and we're
like back to back but right but you did
well uh went great and uh I even popped
over to the open mic at the secret group
you're sick I know well we had nothing
to do we were bored and my friend you
know Andrew Youngblood yeah he owns this
club so he's like you want to go drink
for free at my club we'll get out of
this green room and I said let's do it
and uh then the open mic was going on I
popped on
and was it how was it it was good it's
usually a nightmare every time I've done
that it's always I always regret it yeah
it's you're dancing with fire or playing
with fire dancing with fires that's not
nice
that's what you mean all right the
headset with fire is that a new album I
don't even know what I'm talking about
no but I mean you have that you come off
that good late show usually and then
you know yeah you want to [ __ ] you want
to lose that feeling that's true it's
the weirdest thing about comedy you got
this hot show sold out you're killing
and then you go do an open mic for 11
people and you've never felt with you
like this is a general thing people this
is just you no one else does this what
would be an equivalent to that like
maybe you're playing in the majors and
then you go hit uh you go to like you
play an NBA and then you go to like a
you know pick up the story that Gary
Payton did that and I really it's true
but the show The Story Goes Gary Payton
if you don't know the glove play for the
Sonics in the 90s he was a badass his
son is in the NBA I love yeah so Michael
Jackson I mean O.J
well he had his love too Michael Jackson
that's true that's true but uh glove no
love but that's a great nickname for
that that's how good you are defensively
you're the glove right so the story goes
he's at like a nightclub and like boat
shoes and some guy's like I could beat
you one-on-one and he's just like no you
can't and he's like yeah I can and
Peyton like it keeps to the point he was
known for [ __ ] talking like this pull up
the picture of Peyton and Michael Jordan
and you just see him in Jordan's face
and like he didn't beat Jordan but you
got to give the guy props for just
getting in the dude's face like [ __ ] you
I love that
um and yeah get that get that image
um he was the glove but in basketball
yeah yeah yeah he's like he's like
that's on you that's how tight he was ah
yeah look at that picture of you know
the one in the corn no the other one
no no the one was in his face dude come
on ah come on Google [ __ ] there you go
oh look at that that's not even the one
I'm thinking that's heated I was talking
top right yeah but look at that yeah I
mean he's way smaller than Jordan he
should not be yeah that's the one I'm
talking about look at him right there
maybe another one well the thing is that
they say is like he wasn't the best
trash talker but he just didn't stop
like it was just the whole game he'd be
like dude shut up yeah right
um how bad could he be like hey you
[ __ ] honky nice uh nice legs like
what is bad trash talking like you stink
I think I think like knowing [ __ ] about
your personal life though people oh yeah
do homework and they're like your wife
the famous one was Kevin Garnett on uh
I'm Carmelo your wife smells like Honey
Nut Cheerios what does that mean just I
know your wife smell because I've been
with your wife it's like a specific oh
wow I know that box
um so anyway some guys challenging him
in the story I don't know if it's true
one on one and he just keeps he's like
fine like [ __ ] it find a park right now
he goes to take him one-on-one in his
street clothes he is an NBA check which
is like probably one check like for
whatever a couple games 48 Grand or
something maybe maybe one game who knows
what it was for yeah puts it there he
goes if you can score one basket on me
you can have this
oh you know how it ends he locks him the
[ __ ] up embarrasses him oh that's great
but you don't realize how good I was I
popped by uh West 4th the park to watch
some hoops just before my seller spots
over the weekend and you're like these
kids are incredible oh really I mean
they don't miss a shot I'm watching my
friend we're like these kids don't miss
one shot think how good pro athletes are
yeah I know right was it a game game or
was it just a pickup no it's a game oh
no uniforms and stuff there's a ref
there's a guy in the mic which looks fun
yeah you know there's a because I walk
by there every single day to go to the
subway and there's always some good some
bad there's a little mix but there's one
son of a bee who stands there and when
you walk by the chain link fence he goes
anywhere point to a spot I'll make a
shot and the first time I was like all
right I got a minute so I go right there
shoots it he makes it he goes give me
another one give me another we'll go
till I I miss and I'm like all right
he'll miss eventually right there he
shoots it he makes it give me another
one he's like an old white guy with a
ponytail so I'm like how many shots can
this guy actually make I was there for
like 28 minutes the guy kept sinking it
that guy's a beast I had no idea I was
like I gotta go man yeah so that was it
you gotta love the old man in the in the
Park oh yeah it was I used to play like
110th and it was like an old man who
just like uh he's just like a fat old
man but he could play yeah there's like
nothing better than old man but he's a
chubby old man yeah and he had handles
and he could shoot and you know and like
the kids weren't locking him up like
they could have sure but it was fun
you know that guy's got some stories he
probably played with uh Isaiah Thomas in
1981 you know
um any any peeves dude oh I gotta pee
for you buckle up for this one and I
hope I haven't said this before I mean
we repeat on this podcast yeah you've
never seen repave
yeah [ __ ] all right repeat for a Dream
so uh how about this guy the guy who has
to let you know he's not a certain thing
when he he tells you something you know
he's like look I'm not a doctor but I
don't think you should be drinking that
much and you're like
do you need to be a doctor first of all
we know you're not a doctor or hey I'm
not a scientist but you better not mix
those two whatever and you're like we
all know you're not a scientist no need
to say it and I'm mixing whiskey and gin
what does that have to do with you being
a doctor like we all know that's bad so
that that pissed me off I had a guy
doing that all weekend oh wow yeah yeah
I'm know this I know this he was like he
was the waiter at the club and he kept
being like I'm no bartender but uh I
don't know about these Long Islands or
whatever and I'm like all right Long
Island no no I'm just I'm making an
example but yeah I hate that you don't
need to tell me you're not a doctor
you're a waiter you have an apron on
you're at a comedy club we know you're
not a doctor yeah no it is I know what
you mean after the third time you're
like wait no yeah and you could tell he
thought he was cool saying it
I'm no architect you don't like cliche
Expressions I hate them I hate them and
then if you use them a lot uh it's even
worse yeah I hear that why what do you
got I mean I'm no therapist but I got uh
no I got you know what bugs me and it's
I I don't know if I've said this either
but uh you ever behind like one person
in line and they take forever if I can
handle a long moving line that takes
even longer just mentally I can handle
that but when you're behind one person
and they just won't move yes what's
happening what is going on there's this
guy there's this guy in front of me at
the bank he just keeps going like I'm
like what this has been 20 minutes and
then and then I hear him go how was your
day to the person I go oh no you didn't
how's your day turn and say how's your
day to me I'll tell you how it's going
[ __ ] bad yeah you're ruining my day
speed it up no small talk when you're
holding up a line no that's crazy this
couple New Yorkers here but how about
this guy I go to Chipotle four times a
day and I open it up with Chipotle I
love Chipotle yeah but
nothing worse because you know you gotta
go down the line give me beans give me
tomato give me guac the taco guy kills
you because if you order tacos you get
three tacos and they go a little bit of
chicken on that one that one beef no
cheese on that one and it just it
triples the length of the lot of the
ordering so I let a guy in you know you
both get to the door at the same time
and I go all right I open the door him
and his friend go in they both get tacos
and you go ah why did I let this Choo
chin
that's it
no I know what you mean anything holding
up a line like especially in New York
there's a fast-paced city you're a New
Orleans guy when you're in New Orleans
maybe it doesn't bug you as much or slow
but it doesn't it bugs me now I've been
you know new yorkified I went to school
there for a year and a half and I
remember being like wow this is making
me crazy it made me crazy the pace even
the way they even the way they speak to
you so how you doing get to it yes Save
we get the G out all right the African
had a joke about how uh people from the
South they move like gravy like we're
just so slow and like
slovenly and it's so true I think it's
because of the food it's hot we're
eating gumbo we're way down
yeah the South the pace it's a different
type of person the pace here you gotta
move it a little bit
um I'll tell you another peeve is you
ever behind like four people and they're
perfectly spread out so they block the
whole sidewalk
yes yes exactly people who are slowing
you down in any way in this city even
when I have nothing to do I'm in a rush
yeah that's part of the city you know so
the four all spread out or the in the
rain I'm not an umbrella guy should the
people who have the two people with the
two umbrellas perfectly apart now
there's no way through yep yep or even
when there's one person but they move
kind of with you yeah
is happening they don't that's true the
Red Rover thing is so crazy because I'm
like I know you have four friends but do
you all have to be side by side I guess
what do you think that is why can't
people walk yeah what are you the
Reservoir Dogs
movie poster yeah that's true it's
brutal don't Build That Wall with your
friends it does uh
uh now there's gonna be someone
competency walls work
um but no it makes me crazy uh the
perfect formation it really makes me I
don't know why or the uh yeah we're just
annoyed by anyone well in the way my
thing is just what do you expect the
rest of us to do you think you're
holding the whole sidewalk you get the
whole city the Avenue the Americas is
you yeah come on what about the rest of
us who have to slide by you
not to mention they're all on their
phones and the whole thing this straw is
terrible I hate the paper straw it's
it's already melty yeah it's closing up
like a [ __ ] vagina around Mark and I
have to listen to this podcast I'll tell
you hey
vaginal walls Build That Wall this is
really uh that's pretty good it's really
good but the straw sucks yeah the straw
is terrible and it doesn't make a
difference oh you got the that's done
oh fun dead it wouldn't be it wouldn't
be a we might be drunk if we weren't
putting something poisonous in our body
you got that right this is a carcinogen
right here good save look we got the
glove here
well done that's not my that's on my I'm
a righty so it's not the right hand but
here we got oh we got a lot of donuts
they won't let you buy one here's a
little this is a fun life hack for you
kids at home go to Dunkin Donuts get a
coffee and then go can I have one
munchkin and that guy goes get the [ __ ]
out of here you Chooch and he throws it
at you that's [ __ ] good because one
would be like 11 cents they should be
paying us for this [ __ ] this is good
wait a minute are these jelly that's a
mix uh geez it's like New York it's
mixed I don't like the jelly gotta put a
towel down
oh she didn't tell me
I didn't know damn it you lied to me but
I'm no chef but these are good Donuts
you want one yeah yeah
here we go all right good hands on this
pod
my girl's got a uh IUD No period really
yeah
and no pregnant I don't know why every
woman doesn't do this the IOD
she hated it for a day or two and also
somebody ever feel the tip of it
sometimes in your pee hole I do it's not
great yeah but at least you're long
enough
it's like the little Microsoft Word
paper clip popping up like hey may I
help you
yeah two urethras now oh yeah yeah it
feels like that it's a weird you feel
that poke it hurts like yeah you can't
cap that off with something yeah we can
put a little like how about like a
little pocket [ __ ] at the end of that
thing oh a double put an air puss on
push yeah push on puss hey enter [ __ ]
why can't we put that at the end of the
is that impossible well this is where my
girl will go oh sorry I put this thing
in my body it hurts like hell then you
get poked oh you're like well I do get
poked
sensitive area but I get it oh yeah why
can't we both complain yeah we have a
problem with that in America like well I
have I go do this like well I go through
this like yeah but mine's worse like all
right but if you cut my leg off
and I cut both your legs off sure yours
is worse but
can I complain about the one leg yeah
all right no I think you can complain I
mean but don't you ever see don't you
ever you ever complain like a shitload
and then you see someone in like the
worst condition ever and you're just
like we're just talking about this I'm
just like what what am I doing with my
life sure you're like this guy's living
in just abject this abject misery right
here he's got no legs he's in a
wheelchair something looks like he's
like a brain injury yeah and then you
got like two more subway stops and
you're like can you move right can you
move human nature it's all relative it
is but when that guy's around
if you do you're like God damn I
complain too much but I think it's all
about gratitude so last night I'm at
Bert kreischer's house he bought this
new house it's unbelievable the pool the
hammock the hot tub the fire pit the
deck the barbecue he's got a gym there
it's insane and he's using all of it I
go out there he's laying in the pool
then he hits the gym then he does a
podcast and then he's got these big dogs
running around and I was like this house
is incredible we did a shoot we had
cigars after by the fire pit he really
uses it he really loves that house and I
feel like a lot of people get rich and
they go I'm bored what's next he's like
utilizing it and enjoying it I think
that's the key do you remember when we
went to Whitney Cummings place in La not
a room there was every room was empty it
was a giant mansion one room was being
used as a podcast Studio that was it and
it had pools tennis courts and what's
under construction I was there too I've
been there too it was under construction
okay I'd rather [ __ ] on her but
she had one room just to cry in
but yeah that's true that house was very
underutilized New York that's just our
only room right right that's just where
we cry and that's the other thing we
live in you know we live in Manhattan so
when I went to this guy's house you're
just like oh my God the front lawn is
huge but you still don't want to move do
you no I'm not going to La I'm not
saying that I don't want to catch on
fire but uh it was just really sweet how
uh how great grateful he was isn't it
funny when when California people were
like we've got weather I'm like your
city is literally on fire in Los Angeles
you're bragging about weather you're God
is sending you a message yes you know
what I mean like this is [ __ ] serious
yeah yeah the the crime is bad the fire
and then the homeless they have a skid
row yeah where'd that term come from now
look it up please yeah Google [ __ ]
I've always wondered what that means
because there's a band Little Shop of
Horrors too that's the song Skid Row oh
really yeah wow Lumberjack camps in the
Pacific North LA's fun and small dogs
it's fun and doses like I was excited to
be there and excited to leave
that weather though is pretty nice okay
bro has its origins in The Lumberjack
camps of the Pacific Northwest there you
go early pioneer days
I don't get it all right they were cut
Lumber along a carved out
area of the Wilderness I guess that's
good bro I don't know why it's called
Skid Row this is like when the teacher
explains something you're like I still
don't understand still don't get it
I'm no Professor but I'm confused
um all right all right well the homeless
is getting out of hand like everywhere
you're topping them up yeah they're
still handsome they are in La you're
like [ __ ] this guy was on like The
Surreal Life a few years ago this is
there's more hands but I feel like ours
are more talented I think here you get a
guy juggling or playing some buckets you
know you got to work for it Broadway
versus uh TV homeless exactly weave the
song and dance homeless here right right
because you know millions of people you
got to stand out yeah you're like this
dude was on cats and Broadway five years
ago yeah he can still crank Out Mr
Mustafa lays on the F train because he's
still got it the homeless in New Orleans
[ __ ] up because they all do the same
[ __ ] yeah they all found a trusty
trumpet somewhere and they learned how
to play it or they have the we do the uh
bottle caps on the bottom and they tap
dance and it's great but I'm like you
see the same uh [ __ ] block to block
you're like yeah yeah When the Saints Go
Marching In come on yeah exactly but
they get pretty good when you got all
day to practice have a joke about that
how you see like a homeless guy come on
the train and he's like uh he he he's
like singing you're like oh my God this
guy's incredible then another guy comes
on he goes I'm homeless I don't have any
money and you're just like ah you came
at a bad time you don't want to follow
the really talented homeless guy you
know that's true yeah you gotta bring it
yeah that was the angle it was like you
know it's like here it's like America's
Got Talent they're like I'm homeless I
don't have any money like and what will
you be performing for us this evening
you did that show awful let's hear it
was this Howard Stern no I think if I
had Stern on I would have done better
yeah I think Stern uh really liked
Comics our boy garyvee made the top five
that's right he likes Comics a lot Howie
Mandela's cool [ __ ] but I was on when uh
when Simon replaced Howard who's like he
was really nice
promo kill me how cool what a cool dude
there we go what do you think it's five
six years ago
my brother
you gotta have a story and my cousin
will be famous in a few years
so 30 for 30.
like I said this is the best part
actually because you I could they had to
cut together me I got a standing out
with this show well it's like a 5 000
seater in the Palisades what oh no
Pasadena not Palisades uh Pasadena but
I'll tell you the backstory for this in
a sec but yeah keep going here this is
oh no keep going the way
the other day I farted I laughed through
the door open the pretty girl came on I
was like that's not funny anymore
and it was my stop I got off door shut
she stuck with a fart
to cut to them all standing here no
leave it after a fart joke is the
dumbest thing I've ever seen and by the
way that set was in LA I'm walking they
were like we'll make it look like I'm
like they're like you're a New Yorker
yeah we can make it look like New York
yeah they just have like a set on some
Lots uh like this is a New York set I'm
like this is I'm so unhappy right now
and then my brother's a lot I love the
way they cut together I'm just doing a
fart joke everyone's like yeah that's
Barry and then uh yeah I remember before
that set these two Jewish rappers went
on and I thought they were like kind of
good and Simon's like you're terrible
you're the worst least talented people
I've ever seen I'm just like oh my God I
gotta follow this then well like they
didn't feed us for the longest time I
was panicking I remember there's like
uh I'm texting my mom like I'm so
anxious it's like I have to be here for
like 12 hours and uh no no hold on a sec
everyone's like freaking out back there
and it and it's one of the things where
they're like uh
yeah we after I got off I got a standing
out after I got off they were like we
don't know if we're gonna use any of
that and I was like I just flew to L.A
wow like a standing ovation like against
like you picture you see Comics bomb on
this [ __ ] oh yeah I'm nervous and
they're mean to you you don't just bomb
you get picked apart yeah and it's like
you have no like that's our biggest fear
is not getting Final Cut and I remember
uh yeah I was I was freaked the [ __ ] out
so uh after that I was like you might
not use and then like later they're like
we're gonna use some of it I was like
thank God yeah all this [ __ ] did you get
a bump because that was a huge show yeah
when it aired it was like a four minute
segment I mean it was like the biggest
it was like 10 million viewers four
million how many I mean four minutes is
a lot yeah I know I mean it's better
than way better than like any because
you think like I think we're like a late
night seconds now like one million 18
times that yeah wow more maybe you know
it was yeah that show when I did it was
huge damn if I went far I think I would
have but I don't think those
those fans are as loyal as like real
estate no no because you see people get
a big bump from it and then it kind of
like Fizzles right I don't know if they
stay with you but they know what they're
doing those
cheeky bastards I did last Comic and
they they heard you like cattle then
they don't feed you they want you to get
a little testy because it helps uh you
know the bickering and the fighting and
all that [ __ ] and we did last Comic they
left us in a van for like an hour
they're like sorry guys it's we're
coming along we got lost we're sitting
in a van now we're all fighting with
each other in the van and then I farted
somebody got pissed and you know it got
ugly and they don't lay out of the van
they're like stay in the van blah blah
then we go and there's no lunch they had
tofu wraps so you know these like fat
black Comics are like what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know like pissed off and then you
got to perform it was brutal I did a
Last Comic I mean those shows are
painful and they really uh I remember
the second so I moved on in that round
in the second round uh
ah God it was like they put me in some
hotel where there's construction so I
couldn't sleep so it's like you're
irritable I'm like I feel like they knew
yeah like what place is getting like
drilling yeah early in the morning then
you get there they're trying to get me
to [ __ ] in other comics in the show I'm
like I'm not gonna do it how did they
try and provoke that they'd be like what
do you like a comic was on bombing and
he's like what do you think of this and
I was just like it's like some crowds
are tough it's like I'm just like
avoiding like I'm not giving them [ __ ]
I'm not I'm not gonna tear someone down
on [ __ ] NBC good for you that's
messed up and then uh although it was
bad but uh I'm not gonna say that [ __ ]
no and then
uh yeah and then I went on at like
midnight I got there like 9 A.M I went
on like midnight and uh I did well still
I did do well but
uh by the way George Lopez was a special
guest judge and I was like come on comic
the comedy yeah give me that Golden
Buzzer dude and I remember uh there was
some like Latino uh dance troupe that
went on earlier uh and he was like you
get the one Golden Buzzer I was like God
damn it you went Latino over comment
come on yeah Latino's gonna win every
time and uh so they and they were they
were really good like they and it was
like you see these people it's like
there's like 12 of them it's so funny
there's like 12 people they all have to
be in like perfect you know sink yeah
they're stretching they're doing all
their things I'm literally I can go on
drunk like you realize what we're doing
is because I'm panicking I'm texting my
mom like oh I'm so nervous and she's
like read a book I'm like read a book
there's two [ __ ] slobs from Atlantic
City dancing Mambo Number Five next to
me you think I can just like get lost in
literature right now come on right this
is insane so I remember uh going out
and I do pretty well like I was like I
mean the the Clips online you can see it
I'm doing I got like a it was like a two
and a half minute set and I probably got
at least one or two Applause breaks I
did pretty well and uh I remember
Simon's like your first set was better
I'm like it's midnight yeah Jesus this
crowd's been here for 10 10 years 10
hours he was really nice in the first
round too so I was like maybe Simon's
like gonna maybe he'll be like my guy
like yeah Simon and I are gonna have
like a a bromance I got a beef my
ex-girlfriend loved Son she's like he's
so sexy I was like what that guy he
sucks and she's like he's something
about me sexy I'm like if if you [ __ ]
him he'd be like your vagina sucks your
tits are bad you need to change genders
or whatever the hell so your [ __ ] is
just Dreadful yeah I mean
but when I did last Comic they hated me
because they do the uh so how do you
feel and you're gonna you're gonna wipe
the floor with these other guys and I'd
be like I don't know maybe and they were
like come on come on like what are you
gonna do are you gonna you're gonna take
these kids to school I'm like well some
of them are pretty good I might flub a
line and they they cut the camera like
you got to be competitive and I'm like
I'm not I'm just I just want to do well
and they hated that they don't realize
you don't want to
it's so nerve-wracking to give someone
your life story and see what they do
with it it's nerve-wracking enough to
share it and you have control but then
when you give it to someone else right
you know it's in their best interest to
make you look foolish because that's
what people respond to yeah it's failure
like we know a comic who went on AGT and
they made him look worse than the actual
set was like they'd cut away to people
like what can you imagine going on and
doing okay and then they just cut to
people like
yeah that was Louis CK
yeah reality sucks oh what is that what
are they trying to show that he got
worked on or something
yeah I got some neck uh suck in you can
see is it possible they just lost weight
I think women find it he's mean and Rich
yeah does he do anything for you as a
lady no really
it's like an older guy they're like
that's a hot older guy
um that's a good question uh uh I don't
know Clooney
it's kind of cliche I know yeah
hmm Harrison sometimes I just see
something nice that he's on Instagram
out of nowhere like the algorithm just
puts him in front of me I'm like okay
but I don't know who they are yeah that
algorithm is pretty good I mean you go
to my for you page and it's
tits Norm Macdonald
asses that's it and like a little bit of
skateboarding I've got tits basketball
and comedy yeah yeah I got Michael
Jordan over Byron uh Russell in game six
or I have uh just some random MILFs uh
cleavage yeah that's what's on your
algorithm or is it just us
[Laughter]
yours are on mine as well but yeah this
tits they keep the world round so we do
have some news oh let's do some news you
guys want to jump into it jump in let's
do it
this is a post uh oh and Frank still in
the news after all these years Tiverton
restaurant that's in Rhode Island right
yeah they wrote
social media post
it's it's hotter than an oven in here
and I should know holy [ __ ] that's uh
not a good not a good uh promo tactic
probably that's what I claim to who
posted it said I didn't know that was
Anne Frank when I posted that makes no
sense yeah what do you think was Greta
thuenberg we don't know that face what
do you think yeah wait so he's like wait
so my perfectly structured joke no
longer works right right what do you
think who do you think it is
even if he thought it was just some
victim from them the Holocaust yeah it's
still [ __ ] up
oh not the famous One
yeah it's really you really don't know
where the world's gonna go you're like
in an attic somewhere where in a diary
and they're like someday some dude with
a bar in Rhode Island he's gonna use you
as a punch line right right
I think she's dealt with worse she can
handle it oh yeah tough tough lady all
right well what else we got Boomer man
is uh really struggling with the old
HTML there but sure you can handle a
computer man this is good Lord
all right
yeah and Frank that's like saying don't
look down you're just gonna look at him
did you read the book of course yeah
yeah did you pretty good he's a good
writer hey we should make that the
comedy we write today Frank comedy
that's about a spring time for Hitler
yeah exactly female heavy strong female
lead ah she's pretty light by the end I
think that's good that's a good point
all right woke Warriors say identifying
race of ancient human remains
contributes to white supremacy oh
activists don't want gender of human
skeletons identified either as they
can't escape they're assigned sex wow
well that's not going to be a problem
for this generation because you can just
pull up their Instagram be like look at
that ass definitely a woman that's true
yeah we got a lot more evidence these
days but that woman who had the ass can
change they could
but also it's like I mean you could just
I think we can say should going forward
too I don't know like I it's like are
you looking at like what does that mean
you're looking at Hitler you're like I
mean he identified as a man we think he
presented as white
I don't know what that means I you know
yeah what is that what does it matter if
they're we get their race what was that
it doesn't they're [ __ ] dead they're
not going to be hurt by who they're
assigned exactly but I don't even get
where white supremacy comes in
I saw this story also uh it had an angle
of saying it was like don't assume their
gender when you dig up a neanderthal to
say it was a male Neanderthal or a
female in the end does it say it was a
neanderthal I think they had bigger
problems back then yeah I think where's
my next meal coming from right was a
pretty big one yeah well here comes a
mammoth yeah exactly
wow we got too much time oldest known
gay all right all right have
archaeologists uncovered the remains of
the first known gay man the male
skeleton was found on its side Facing
East obviously a homo
and I'm surrounded by domestic jugs well
maybe not good
objects objects previously seen only in
female Graves and oval egg-shaped
container usually associated with female
burials was also found at the feet of
the skeleton well I saw this article and
I think it's because some men were you
know they were buried with like a bad
lacks or something like that and this
guy was buried uh streaming The Real
Housewives so I think the true test if
we got the skeleton you got to go off
wrist yeah you know if we gotta we got a
[ __ ] up lip wrist that's the gay test
when I see egg-shaped container I'm
thinking that's the vibrate
[Music]
was that a good vibrator the egg yeah
uh you remember that old Apollo joke
he's like I was hooking up with a girl
she pulled out a dildo looked like a
pepper shaker
that's great my girl texted me this
weekend which I don't know how to take
this she goes uh I can't find my
vibrator charger and I'm like all right
well it's fun I know you're about to
jerk it but also I'm not there and
you're jerking but also
you have a vibrator I don't know it was
a you thought of me for a weird reason
yeah you think of me to help you come
you thought of me to help you find the
thing that's gonna help me come that's a
great Point that's weird yeah I don't
know that show's my role my role isn't
getting her off it's it's you know
helping her fix [ __ ] yeah you want to be
on the [ __ ] on the floor you don't
want to be an assistant coach here right
but I wasn't there you're the I.T guy
for her coming yes hello customer
service
thank you come again all right what
about yeah that's uh that's weird that's
interesting but we never have to notify
them when we're gonna ah good point
I still do though I don't have to but
I'm like just want to let you know I'm
jerking one yeah Phil Hanley our boy
that is a joke about uh a girl's day and
said uh do you do you jack off to me and
he goes oh yeah he goes it's an easy
crime to cover up
that's true his other one I don't know
if it's in this special maybe we'll cut
this out if it is but I mean all right
it's gonna be out soon anyway
I'm special yeah the girl I'm seeing
sent me a a still photo of her boobs and
she said I want you to jerk off to this
and he's like what am I a World War II
GI uh uh that's true that's true it's
hard now and we've with the porn we have
it's very relatable women will sometimes
ask you like like oh did you jack off to
that and you're like you you want to see
my browser history do you want to see
what it's taken for me to not yeah now
here's why women and men are different
1980s comedian but let's get him a
[ __ ] Blazer please I'll roll the
sleeves up uh
if Phil Han Phil Hanley sent me that
photo of her tits and I jerked off to
him and I was like hey I saw your tits
and jerked off to him she'd be like what
the [ __ ] but if I set my gal a dick pic
and she sent it to a friend and her
friend jerked off to my dick
I'd be through the through the roof I'd
be on the moon
[Music]
I'm with you okay I think you're right
totally stuck in the process but I think
yeah it's a it's a fair point yeah yeah
it's less violating yeah if you if a
woman saw a picture of my dong and had
to rub one out I don't care who it is it
could be my aunt I'd be flattered
maybe not the end maybe the uncle also
Phil's girl sends him a picture of her
tits
um it's less exciting than if you saw
his girlfriend's tits that is also true
yeah supposed to see him I had a woman
dump I want to do a bit about is that a
woman dump a bottle of wine in my bed
like by accident and I was like oh my
God and then she goes she just grabbed
my dick Lee I'll make it up to you and
I'm just like that's [ __ ] female
privilege yeah can't ruin your [ __ ] and
be like all right whip out your vagina
that's so cheap I mean no I'll make it
up to you all right after that you told
me you're like I just had the worst
night you're up all night right oh yeah
oh that's a bad night tough night Shea
had that great joke about like how on
his birth on his girlfriend's birthday
he would get her flowers chocolate take
her out to dinner on his birthday she
would blow him and he's like that should
be a Tuesday yeah that should be a
birthday we should just be blowing each
other all the time again female priv
yeah so yeah you're not going to turn
down to BJ but yeah no it's no they
didn't have another privilege joke you
just told me an hour ago about your
sneakers
oh that wasn't even a joke uh one time
me and Shay were hanging out and I
showed up and I had some new balance on
I had a hole in the sneaker and he goes
That's white privilege because I think
as we were talking about I think black
people they dress so sharp because if
they don't people are like what's up
with that guy you know so that's like oh
you never think about that wow you know
yeah like Bill Burr that great bit of a
hoe he's like black guys with dirty
sneakers scare the [ __ ] out of me
which is that's kind of profound yeah
yeah wow his bit speaking of didn't you
see the new Burr special we did we
talked about it it really blew it up
yeah we blew it up we loved it yeah I
love Bill he's so good hey folks we
might be drunk It's brought to you by
raycon
I've been listening to a lot of Rolling
Stones lately and it's been great
whatever you listen to it'll sound
better with raycon earbuds raycons
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever they fit perfectly and
don't budge raycons offer three sound
profiles noise isolation plus mode and
awareness mode raycon lets you listen
whatever way you want I like them I use
them to jog and they don't fall out
that's my favorite thing about it the
sound is good they they they envelop the
whole ear and they they fit in they
never fall out and I jog and uh they
sound great and I don't hear all the
[ __ ] around me so uh I'm a big noise
isolation guy great on planes too trying
out those pesky
uh unaborted kids get the same quality
audio as other premium audio brands at
half the price with wireless charging
raycon gives you eight hours of play
time and a 32 hour battery life check
out raycon's wireless earbuds go to
byracon.com
might be drunk one word today to get 15
off your raycon order that's
b-u-y-r-a-y-c-o-n.com slash we might be
drunk one word to score 15 off your
order buy recon.com we might be drunk
just might be drunk just might be drunk
sorry I'm used to saying it that way
that's
m-i-g-h-t-b-e-d-r-u-n-k one word break
on get on it now a word from our sponsor
betterhelp sometimes you can fix it on a
problem for so long that you don't take
time to find a solution it could be
tough to train your brain to stay in
problem solving mode when faced with a
challenge in life when you learn how to
find your own Solutions there's no
better feeling the therapist can help
you become a better Problem Solver
making it easier to accomplish your
goals no matter how big or small
I think therapy is important I'm in
therapy uh he mostly blames my mom it
works pretty well for me uh no she's a
great woman it's therapy is good you
work on your [ __ ] you deal with it so
you don't uh you know blow it up on
someone else it's like it's like jacking
off your way to you let it load too long
you become horny as [ __ ] you try to [ __ ]
everything do that with therapy is that
a bad plug we'll see better health is
online therapy that offers video phone
and chat therapy sessions you can choose
not to see anyone on camera it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com drunk today to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp.com
drunk all right so Brooklyn Bishop
robbed during sermon taking over a
million dollars in jewelry
damn whoa
whoa sure this was a bishop and not an
old lady from Boca
why does a bishop have a million dollars
in jewelry he doesn't I think this is a
work I think this is a WWE work what
just like raise money he's laying down
while the robbers come in oh there's a
robbery this guy on the left is like a
assistant pastor or something just not
moving that's a good camera man though
he's like let me let me get all this
we'll get it captioned we'll blow it up
on IG what the [ __ ]
this guy isn't doing anything I'm so
confused yeah everything's off screen
here is there an audience
I think it's recording it on TV oh
where's your God now bish
so they're robbing him his jewelry here
man it's taking a long time wow wow
wow robbing a bishop
I wonder if that's a worse crime than
robbing a regular
is it I don't know I don't know I think
that's like only with cops probably
officer down yeah yeah you shoot an
officer it's way worse punishment
oh okay yeah we didn't need a video for
that that wasn't like a very exciting
video damn that was a gun point you saw
the hooded guys come in and everything
that was wild yeah dude you know my
parents got held up at gunpoint when I
was 14 at my house yeah that's why we
moved eventually
damn I remember in New Orleans at my the
one night my friends went out without me
like I was just like I stayed in they
went out they got held up at gunpoint
New Orleans man they [ __ ] yeah scary
what happened with your parents I was at
a Mardi Gras parade and it was like a
Thursday night I was out with a bunch of
friends catching beads getting drunk and
I came home there's a bunch of cop cars
and uh you know I see my mom talking
with police
I cry I'm freaking out I'm like what the
hell cause you just assumed they're dead
you see all the cop cars the name of the
movie you're running in slow motion yes
exactly and you know you run into cop
goes you better not he's holding me I
push him off me like you're underneath
they're playing Gimme Shelter
yeah so I see my brother my dad and
they're all talking to the police and
the cops are you know doing this [ __ ]
and I'm like oh okay they're all okay
and then one of the cops told me what
happened I just broke down and then this
is this this is stupid 16 or 15 year old
boy thinking I go get in the car boys
and me and my friends drive around New
Orleans aimlessly like if we see those
guys wearing my mom's pearls and my
brother's shoes or whatever we're gonna
get out and beat the [ __ ] out of them
meanwhile it's like two scary x-cons
with guns but we're like let's drive
around you know my friends are like okay
and I'm looking up let him know let them
run out of steam just keep driving yeah
yeah exactly the second you see them you
run out you're like you piece of [ __ ]
immediately get shot yeah yeah that was
but they caught the guys did they they
went because they took the credit cards
and the ATM and they went to the ATM and
then we got the video footage my dad
id'd him they're wearing clean Sneakers
but they turned out they were your
brothers
yeah yeah exactly likely so they got him
but that that was like the last paper
straw and we got the hell out of there
did your mom give him the code to the
ATM Bosco did yeah did that happen yeah
oh yeah all of us code Bosco that's uh
yeah yeah that's scary that's right
Bosco George likes Bosco and after that
my mom had to go to therapy and that was
in the 90s when it's like oh [ __ ] she
needs therapy they have to cut through
every person we know in therapy yeah now
it's like we're in like a real therapy
movement right now oh yeah it's a good
time to be a therapist that job was
really pandemic proof too like holy [ __ ]
yeah that was like the only job that got
like better during the pandemic you're
like oh I don't have to pay for an
office anymore I just chill at home and
right good point did you do therapy yeah
I was gonna say they're at home mine had
to like check on muffins well oh yeah
mine would have his wife like talking to
him he's like I'm in a session I'm gonna
be like hold on one second let me just
I'm like yeah this never happened when I
I went to your office
yeah my therapist is Running a
Restaurant he had an Anne Frank poster
but his jokes were good yeah
take a text while you're in therapy your
therapist therapist will be like this is
really hostile what you just did to me
meanwhile just got this guy is taking
therapy sometimes oh I yeah not face to
face no I don't okay
well it's because it would pop I'd have
to I so much will get to shut off
and if it's nothing important I don't
respond but uh you know sometimes
something pops up yeah that's true and
you can't help but see if a text pops up
on your phone and you see it you can't
ignore it because now your brain is
thinking about that and processing that
you always feel like you like that one
hour is like when Hollywood's gonna call
like they want you to be the new
Spider-Man I'm like I'm like dude I
missed it yeah I was bettering myself
but Andrew Garfield's out Sam morel's in
I'm like no like it expired it was only
for it was only for 13 minutes but
that's the thing is yeah every time
every phone break I'm putting my phone
down I'm putting it on airplane mode and
then you open it and your mom's like I'm
having another kid are you 71. what's
going on here you just look back it just
says rape 40 times you're like what yeah
what the hell you look behind you a
guy's raping you
should answer my text you do that does
happen though it's like question mark
question like the one time I put my
[ __ ] phone down I know I know but
then really do you ever really miss
anything I know I know my therapist
doesn't I mean he's he's pretty good
about but the one thing is he's older so
I will deal with like Tech [ __ ] on the
uh on the zoom sometimes I can't hear
you I'm like I hope this isn't coming
out of my time right here yeah right
that's true you ever had them cancel on
you feels pretty good that's a good
feeling it's good because you're like
yeah okay I got some I'll do something
else yeah cause I don't really want to
go but I know I have to right so when
they cancel you're like it's it's nice
what do you add about uh once every two
weeks every week every week what are you
doing I do once it's every two now yeah
I've been spacing it out mostly yeah but
uh I don't know the weekly was I was
making up stuff
you know I was like I'm out I'm out of
[ __ ] like how about the those Nets you
know you're making up [ __ ] well yeah I
was running out of [ __ ] but I had to
fill it up and pay it for the guy yeah
you're running bits yeah it's not a bad
place to like sneak a bit in it that's
true because like he's not faking last
that's true you know and I've told you
[ __ ] that that Alan has said to me and
you're like that's a bit so I've gotten
bits at it two of you you get bits there
and also yeah because also it's like a
place your mind is free like if you
don't look at text for like an hour
you're like holy [ __ ] my brain is moving
at a different speed and you're
unloading and You're vulnerable so it's
almost like a podcast when I do get a
laugh out of him I'm like I take it down
I'm like how many people take notes in
therapy and he goes you're the only one
I was like all right good you take notes
I take notes what if he says something
really heavy I wanna I don't want to
forget it oh see if he says something if
he says something really good I don't I
know I will forget if I don't take a
note that's a good observation I film it
film the whole thing I bring a camera in
there well speaking of bits you guys
cooking up anything oh I got a hot one I
got some ideas you go first I need your
help on an ending but it's it's I
finally have a good one I feel like the
last four weeks I've been bombing with
the new [ __ ] that's kind of what this
is for I feel weird when I bring
something too prepared on here true but
sometimes my shit's either so bad it's
not worth bringing in or it's kind of
finished exactly it's hard to find that
middle ground sometimes exactly yeah
yeah uh so
uh one of our friends is sober I wonder
who this could be about yeah exactly
we've got a couple sober friends that's
true but he's sober because the last
time he got shit-faced he [ __ ]
somebody and got herpes yeah so now he
has herpes yeah but every time we hang
out
we can't drink obviously because he's
sober so we have to like have all these
activities we have to go [ __ ]
bicycling or canoeing and I'm like or
repelling and I'm like dude just because
you have herpes doesn't mean we have to
do the commercial wow that's funny and
that hits and now I'm like all right now
where do I go with it so I thought about
like what about the side effects you
know you always hear herpes medication
side effects and uh he's like yeah this
medication on the side effects or like
depression laziness uh suicidal thoughts
and I'm like maybe I have herpes and
that's one way I might go with it well I
would take out laziness because you're
being active in the joke too so I would
say like depression uh Suicidal Thoughts
uh you know hiking anxiety or neurotic
yeah nervoses explosive diarrhea you're
like [ __ ] I think I have herpes right
right
so the first part is hitting and I might
try that one tonight on some show that
that second part because I feel like a
joke has to have It's gotta have a
little more than just that one laugh
yeah it feels like I'm leaving [ __ ] on
the table here yeah no I think that's
funny I mean I also think it's funny
that like you have to be more active
because he has herpes yeah like his
mistake is making you do cardio now oh
that's good look I gotta go [ __ ] I have
to go shoot hoops in the park because
you [ __ ] the chick with an STD this is
crazy but it's making my life better
hopefully you get uh chlamydia next
thing I know I'm uh I got a 12 pack you
know next time I'm in a triathlon it's
like the new P90X
yes he drank a 12-pack you've got a
12-pack ah there you go there we go
nice Hector Salamanca
okay what do you got so I had one I
don't know where to go yet but like the
idea is like I'm looking at apartments
and
it's a lot like uh going on dates
you know what I mean like you look at
the apartment and then you're like wow
this is at first you're like this is
great and then like and then after a
minute you're like oh [ __ ] whoever was
here last did a real number on this
place I don't know oh that's good like
the last guy might have [ __ ] this up a
little bit that's good you know what I
mean that's good like the first part did
okay well I'm just like yeah it's a lot
like internet dating the pictures always
look better online I thought it was like
whatever yeah then this that's the line
that hit the line where I'm like whoever
was here last really [ __ ] it up I
don't know where to go next it's like
one of them was like it'd be easier to
go dating if you had like a dating
realtor like someone to like make you
who built up the person you're dating
with maybe like that someone who's like
uh this this girl have you seen this
girl she's already gotten multiple
offers today like this girl because I
was looking at a place and this guy was
like trying to show you ever go to one
of these play this may be a different
bit but this guy is like he's like dude
this building like you this building's
gonna blow you away we're in the
elevator he's like you see how fast that
elevator was I'm like you're not gonna
sell me on an apartment I'm not Amish
yeah yeah the elevator's not shocking me
yeah well
I try to do a bit like this and David
tell had a similar bit so I dropped but
I was doing Tinder and Zillow how
similar they are but this is different
yeah but I dropped it I know how to tell
a bit where he's like I'd like to dump a
load and that it like washer dryer
exactly dump a hot load in that yeah but
how about with the difference between
dating and apartment hunting is you
wanna you wanna make it serious
immediately like if you like the
apartment you're like
I'm moving in though yeah you know you
with a girl you're like I'll move in in
a year yeah or two years or whatever I'm
not signing [ __ ] yes exactly you're like
hey with an apartment and you're not
like what else do you have you know yeah
yeah oh and how about uh the last guy
[ __ ] this up but she's got a lot of
work done
no differences like work done on an
apartment is good work done on a woman
is not as good yeah we go he was like
signing a lease and signing a prenup
right right new kitchen new face yeah
yeah new kitchen new tits although come
on
oh how about that
but this place was uh really fun I mean
we went in the back door uh
hahaha
that's risk he's doing I mean
considering we feel like [ __ ] this isn't
like the worst you know yeah I did a KFC
radio today no no this is like last week
and you know it's a bar stool yeah I go
in there they're all watching us on the
everybody there is me you doing this
show and then I saw one they were
watching uh Chrysler one was watching
tiger belly I'm like I was walking down
the hot the halls there I was getting
high fives dude I gotta go and feed so I
closed the bar down on Saturday night
yeah I'm drinking at a classic New York
place called Corner Bistro
thank you
but uh yeah we were there all night and
uh my boy John Weisberg we're hanging
getting lit up that's a great spot the
bartender is cool [ __ ] this guy Jack and
he goes uh he made some comment and uh
and then he's like what he we were
talking for a while and he's like what
do you do I said I'm a comic and
whatever and he's like oh man I used to
bartender this place and they get all
kinds of huge names popping in you know
like this guy Mark Norman my friend and
I we both started laughing our ass off
yeah that's a that's a low bar for us
scrape on the barrel at this place
I knew he wouldn't be able to take that
compliment you know what but the the new
the new compliment is uh my friends are
sending me [ __ ] like on dating apps and
they're like
guys like I know a girl like guys are
using you in their photo as their as
their cover that's a big one that's kind
of nice yeah but that is nice yeah so
thanks for sending those ladies oh yeah
well wait this is Corner Bistro yeah
yeah go in there sometimes I love that I
get it there all the time that's one of
my favorite Village spots very Village
we were drinking a lot of vodka all
night and then at some point we were
drunk enough that we switched to White
claw and let me tell you something man
white Claw is [ __ ] good it goes down
easy I like white black cherry white
claw that's [ __ ] good that's my
favorite flavor too love it but the
hangover is nothing nice yeah why is The
Hangover so bad because it's all corn
syrup it's all chemicals is there a lot
of corn syrup in it
um
it's Malt Liquor yeah it doesn't say
what the liquor is so it's like a malt
lick exactly yeah it really [ __ ] you I
really was hurting yeah it's a smart
drink though because it's so light and
Airy that you feel like you're not doing
anything then three later you're like
I'm hammered yeah I was not feeling good
yeah you don't end on white claw so you
close the place out like what 4 AM what
is that 4 AM yeah wow that's impressive
thank you yeah it really is impressive
impressive is really the right word for
that not a sad and pathetic well that's
the problem with Houston or been to New
York you're the bar close at four you go
home you go to bed in Houston the bar
closes and then we would go to a
friend's house and drink there because
everybody's house is so big and there's
a big couch you don't bring people to
your house in New York yeah you know
it's too tight tight yeah any wrecks by
the way I watched the bear on your wreck
it's incredible it's pretty good right
man that main all the acting's
incredible that main dude I'm like holy
[ __ ] like that's like and and the guy
who plays the cousin I'm like that's
like a that's like that's like a De Niro
Mean Street yes Eric Roberts Pope and
Greenwich Village
season of Girls he's excellent oh really
amazing yeah they're all I mean the cast
is so good it's beautifully It Feels So
Chicago yeah the big malort sign yes I
love it I love when something is a love
letter to a city like that it captures
it with the L train and everything I
know some people that don't like it I
talked to a couple people that don't
like it but it's so up our alley I feel
like the way that that tension so fast
episode is so good oh have you I
finished it yeah oh my God it's great
not to give anything away but the first
half of the last episode where they just
oh it's heavy get there baby I also have
heard I haven't seen this show but I've
heard the new show uh also on FX
uh the old man is incredible I heard
that too actually
my parents love it and our boy Ronan was
like it's so good he hates everything he
hates everything he's such a [ __ ]
hater interesting are you guys watching
the offer people keep wrecking that to
me I know I haven't seen it Miles Teller
yeah yeah it's uh it's the story of this
it's a patron the making of of The
Godfather yeah yeah I mean you can't go
wrong with Jeff Bridges and John Lithgow
I know right two Titans by the way we
see you guys harassing Charlie Sheen on
social media yeah this podcast keep
coming baby keep hitting up the sheen
even Simon Rex our boy even texts me did
he text you no he said I'm listening to
the Pod I hear the sheen it's off loud
and clear I've already text him about it
he said haven't heard back he might have
changed his number like he changed his
number a lot we're getting one degree of
separation exactly we're there exactly
that's like that's what cool party dudes
do they change their number a lot yeah
that's true I gotta do that I have the
same numbers as high school me too I ran
to some of the street he was like same
numbers like yeah yeah yeah same same
people always go what's your number and
I write it down they go 504 New Orleans
I'm like yeah same number that
expression I've got your number oh yeah
where's that from that's gotta be that
It's gotta be that well I've got your
number yeah 917. are you 917. damn when
646 came in I was kind of like I want no
part of that what about three one four
is the other one there's another's a
third New York I don't know I think it's
three one four two one two is a New York
one two one two as well
that's it three four seven sorry damn
late bloomer sorry bro
sorry dude Put the gun down matt put it
down oh [ __ ] he's dead yeah he [ __ ]
killed himself
sorry I think we went a week without a
shooting
did we hey look at us depending when
this comes out yeah good boy and also
depending what you consider a shooting
that's definitely not true that's true
that's 100 not true yeah you got me
there bro so you're doing a wreck there
mark would I'll look this up oh yeah I
didn't even give one either I just oh
the bear no but that was Mark's wreck I
was commenting on the wreck that he gave
that I now watched well I could wreck
Pedialyte also I want to give a shout
out to high noon because that is the
best seltzer I think yeah exactly I
can't wait till we do those rpds is that
what they call those little canned uh
drinks oh yeah yeah
RTD sorry when I call them rpds
role-playing game yeah RPD red RTD
sorry we're gonna I want to do old Pals
I want to do Manhattans I want to do
boulevardier's yeah and you don't see
those so that'll be exactly old Pals
that sounds great and I gotta give a
shout out to our guy Chris who's the
whiskey distiller
uh and I had lunch with him in Houston
he got us the steaks and shrimp and
oysters look at me he was texting me
what he gave me some great bottles to
take home did he give you some bottles
no no what the hell you took you to
dinner yeah but uh I drank something
last night it's great he gave me great
whiskey oh he knows his stuff I I'm
pumped I mean he's been fun to work with
I think we're gonna have this I know
Bodega cat's been taking forever guys
it's it's really we're this close now
it's like getting past some [ __ ]
state laws but like we're there it's
coming it'll be online first and then
eventually he's gonna he said he's gonna
send us 10 cases dude it's going and
we'll send it to our friends and
families I'll bring bottles out I mean I
already brought it to The Cellar one
night I was drinking it with uh Phil
Hanley Liz the manager Shane Gillis they
were all very very impressed yeah it's
gonna be at the Comedy Cellar by the end
of the year hell yeah and like you can
order it the comedy seller yeah that's
gonna be [ __ ] cool how in New York is
that trip how New York is that trip you
go to The Cellar and you get both yeah
yes good point wait wait you're the
distributed yeah I work with the
distributor so hopefully it comes my way
see it's all locking in I would love to
get that on menus please let's get that
[ __ ] she's in with every bar in the city
let's get into some classic bars in New
York what are some classic bars that
need a Corner Bistro I mentioned it to
him and he was like we'll see I'll bring
a bottle in man oh please I'll [ __ ]
bring him back and do it Mark oh yeah
I'm a big shot he's a big shot I'll
bring a head holy [ __ ] are you big name
comedian Mark Norman we got stopped in
the street on the way here some guy goes
hey man I'm a comedian no no and he
first said hey you're sexy hey you sexy
beast or something nice and I was like
oh hey and he goes I gotta talk to you
which immediately I'm like I'm out I
don't want to talk to you you're out of
the closet yeah I'm out of the closet
and he goes I gotta talk to you and I'm
like all right well there you go I'm a
comedian I go all right let's win the
deal and I got out of there literally
everything that Mark doesn't want to
hear yeah do my podcast and you're like
all right
there's no
no fit me
anymore oh I know you know it'll be like
can I do your product can you give me
some tips can you take me on the road
whatever it is so yeah how's that
Pedialyte treating you grape is a good
flavor you want to try it I think I said
it's [ __ ] delicious love a little
gray it's a great flavor grape culture
this poor bastard was on the red eye
today oh yeah got off a red eye this
morning yeah dude I took listen to this
uh cocktail of of sleeping pill I took
three melatonin half a Xanax one
sleeping pill and an edible you gotta be
careful I slept the whole thing I didn't
I I didn't even plug my phone in because
I fell asleep so early and I woke up to
oh
yeah a bad landing is really the worst
thing it was bad but it woke me up I had
a bad landing recently it was the last
flight I took really bad landing and
just like we just went boom everyone's
like oh my gosh what's good about that
is you don't have long enough to be
scared that's true because it just
happened you're like what the [ __ ] man
try not to make a Kobe we're gonna keep
it moving but yeah yeah bad landing is
rough you know what else is a [ __ ] and
a flight is uh when you do you sleep on
planes I'm I can't uh not even a cat nap
I if I if I'm in one of those lay Flats
I can maybe oh yeah but I'm still sick
three so those [ __ ] lay flats are
even I'm even in those lay Flats I'm
kind of my toes are kind of peeking out
that's true yeah uh can you sleep I can
sleep pretty good I can get like an hour
but I drool
so first off I wake myself up going
then you're all embarrassed and then
you're like uh ah it's on your shirt
so it's a mess terrible but it's working
it's a really bad guy on the way back
from Costa Rica I did a red eye too and
every like this was dark in the plane
quiet yeah every so often you just hear
yeah
I hate that you loud yon guys would ping
the you know the guy do you think you're
trying to get your attention no he was
just that's just him he was something
was off because then when the guy came
he'd be like can I get a Pepsi with ice
like screaming he's right here and
everyone just woke up yeah I don't want
to I don't want to get you guys riled up
here you two but we had a nice peaceful
plane ride you know it's red eyes so
those lights go off immediately Orthodox
Jewish kids hey they wouldn't shut the
[ __ ] up everybody hated them
brutal they had the the hair thing going
and everything the payus yeah brutal
don't don't make a past joke I didn't
want I got it out do it but every kid on
the plane was by a Hispanic kid black
kid white kid but those Orthodox Jews
would not shut the [ __ ] up well there
was that story years ago where like
these these Orthodox Jews would not uh
like they won't sit next to women on
flights
she said the flight gets delayed oh and
it's like you gotta check your religion
on the flight exactly what do you say
about the red eye or being on a plane at
all so like I mean it didn't help I was
throwing bacon at him but Mark all right
[ __ ] you pass
[ __ ] you pay me leave your religion off
the flight you hear that Isis we're on
the plane take it in that one more so
that one's more upsetting than the than
the loud Jewish kids it's close
I hope this episode doesn't get flagged
on YouTube no YouTube is cooler than
Instagram right Instagram will flag
[ __ ] anything everybody's getting
flagged now I'm [ __ ] Shadow banned
still really what's going on I don't
know how do you get out of it
only one way out a John Wick type
Revenge Journey
Billy Wayne Davis a comedian friend
funny guy he did a Tucker Carlson joke
and it got flagged so it's like you get
it on both sides yeah it's crazy
everybody's nervous I got a toast
I love it never done it we haven't done
it in a while I got a new one it's a
weird one but a toast to Pantry items
Pan peanut butter tuna beans they're
[ __ ] clutch sometimes you're just
like I don't have time I just want to
open a can of tuna I want to make a
quick melt yeah I like the pantry items
I like how you can kind of bust them
open whenever you feel it they don't go
bad they don't go bad the peanut butter
you don't have to refrigerate it you
just pop it open you take a scoop I do
that every morning love a pantry item
all right I never heard of it referred
to as a patriotic is that another Pantry
item yeah what about a cupboard it could
also be a cupboard item all right all
right well my side checked out okay you
know I like I like uh some tuna tuna is
always so tuna I eat it out of the can
only I'll put a little olive oil on salt
on that's what I do you know what I do
sometimes a little olive oil everything
bagel seasoning oh I got the same thing
I get crazy pepper flakes I go Ranch
you mix it up a little it's like a tuna
salad that sounds nice I mean you do
Mayo why not a Tangy or Mayo have you
seen this tuna in a bag uh oh those
sealed hermetically sealed yes they have
a hotel lobby sometimes yeah you're
drunk at the end of the night I'm like
give me that tune in this whole team
I've done the same thing that's a sad
moment right there yeah
I got leftovers at a restaurant put it
in my mini fridge in the hotel forgot
about it got drunk woke up now I got
this it's basically beef stew and rice
congealed no microwave it's four in the
morning I got no Fork I don't want to be
an animal and use my hands I noticed
there's two coffee stirrers on a little
coffee thing Chopstick situation exactly
I take them and I force-fed myself that
fatty Brown viscous jizz all night and
went to bed love it yeah I had the
eating ass uh ring around my face when I
woke the Rocky music plays he's like
figuring it out yeah
nothing worse too when you wake up in a
hotel and the sheets are dirty from
doing this [ __ ]
oh dirty sheets in a hotel you're just
like I'm who raised me what kind of
animal am I it looked like a big skid
mark I'm gonna leave that extra tip too
and you're like I'm really gross this is
a really I left this room gross yeah
yeah we're getting a lot I know we got
to wrap this thing up have you ever look
down a hotel you're walking down a hall
hotel hallway and you look in some rooms
they have the door open there's some
wild [ __ ] going on in there like boxes
of snacks and Waters and just stuffed
animals and they're like how long are
you living here
gross all can't play this yeah you think
you think we have the rights to Bill
Conte is that who that is isn't it wow
good it is wow what a pull oh this you
better believe this is on my gym
playlist there's a [ __ ] wreck for you
a gym playlist yeah that's love a gym
playlist that is that'll [ __ ] get you
ready to go down I mean you're hungover
and I forced myself to go to the just
bike a little bit do some push-ups like
I have to force myself with I was so
hungover but I was like I'm gonna hate
myself if I don't work out and take a
cold shower yeah but yeah you got that
gym playlist got a little of that [ __ ]
on there got a little bit of do a little
dance
make a Little Love Get Down Tonight
great composer too gym playlist I don't
know if you know him
what do you got in there uh
uh what's on my uh gym playlist I go uh
I go sadly I go 90s alternative like
what what are we talking I feel alive
uh you know Pearl Jam [ __ ] like that
Mark's getting yoked to Third Eye Blind
yes Sammy Trump got a lot baby yeah
Mambo Number Five Thong Song it's all
90s do you really have all issues I love
the 90s Sugar Ray oh I can fly
that's the only guy who left the
Rockstar life to be on extra that's true
what a weird it's like do you want a
tour is a rock star he's like no I'd
rather be the guy who comes out when
you're in a hotel on the road
yeah him and Smash Mouth yeah well
actually no he's do they still go
they're still touring they're still
touring they have some [ __ ] they have
some they're catchy
lead singer like wasted like nothing oh
good for singing on stage pull him up he
looks like an evil Guy Fieri
they've got some you can pretend you
don't like him when you hear it
you're in a good mood when you hear that
[ __ ] yeah it's fun that was in the movie
Shrek look at that that's Guy Fieri uh
the twin evil twin guy fettuccine
Jamie's singing all right we got uh I
mean some of those songs are fun man uh
yeah I mean they're cheesy but they're
fun they're fun walking on the Sun hits
for a reason that that made them
billions I bet I think
billions I think I made a billion not
even close to the I think someone else
owns those songs because they're very
heavily sampled all right maybe not
billions I don't know anything about
numbers
good show
we gotta wrap this thing I'm gonna wrap
this up tour dates should we do some
touring oh yeah what do you got here I'm
going off the Dome well my special is
coming out on September 1st oh Netflix
you better [ __ ] watch that [ __ ] uh
did you say Netflix yes sir same time
tomorrow did you announce that just now
no no it was last week good for you Jack
thank you bro now are you doing uh I
don't know what do you do on the
internet like a Premiere thing where you
talk to the fans and an hour before I'll
figure it out same time tomorrow
September 1st Netflix tell your friends
uh uh I'll be on uh I'll be in
Burlington Vermont coming up uh Dania
Beach Louisville Miami oh not Miami what
does that say Irvine I'm [ __ ] blind
Omaha Phoenix Lexington New Brunswick
OKC Springfield Missouri Fort Wayne
Indiana Happy Thanksgiving to me
Kansas City Tacoma Spokane see you on
the road samrail.com
shows and those are the shows you want
to go to because uh you'll the Netflix
will be out so you'll be working it out
yeah
uh go see the Craftsman
crafting I will be in oh geez
yeah well I'm going off the top of the
Dome Seattle Portland Maine Portland
Oregon Vancouver
uh Toronto New Orleans Boston and
keep going keep going show all dates
keep going keep going
uh Richmond Funny Bone Red Rocks
Amphitheater uh
something in Bakersfield at the Brewing
Company San Jose Improv Toronto Canada
in October oh Lincoln Nebraska
oh Pittsburgh the roxian theater and
Royal Oak Michigan Theater there so uh
oh Philly at the Fillmore Nashville
Boston New Haven Connecticut so come on
out say hello best pizza in the country
brother Pepe's yeah very good Sinatra
used to get it uh delivered to his house
all right that's it we might be drunk
get yourself a drink a Pedialyte a fake
tit and we'll see you out there folks
thank you thank you Jamie Jamie
Salamanca Sally Gotham Studios Matt
Peters hey I gotta piss close
[Music]
talking [ __ ] about the [ __ ] post and
I get down in the same way
[Music]
dangerous
I'm out to lunch
[Music]
we might be true
[Music]